Y creo que cuando experimentamos con estos posibles futuros de robots,
en realidad aprendemos mucho más sobre nosotros mismos
que sobre estas máquinas.
Y lo que aprendí ese día
fue que yo tenía muchas expectativas en este pequeño amigo.
Pensaba que él no solo podía navegar el mundo físico,
sino también mi mundo social,
él está en mi espacio; es un robot personal.
¿Por qué no me entendió?
Mi anfitrión me explicó,
"El robot intenta ir del punto A al punto B,
y eras un obstáculo en su camino,
así que tuvo que replanificar su camino,
averiguar a dónde ir,
para luego llegar de otra manera".
Lo que en realidad no resulto ser algo muy eficiente.
Si ese robot hubiera descubierto que yo era una persona, no una silla,
y que estaba dispuesta a apartarme de su camino
si él quería llegar a alguna parte,
entonces realmente habría sido más eficiente
al hacer su trabajo
si se hubiera molestado en entender que yo era un humano
y que tengo posibilidades distintas de las que tienen objetos como sillas y paredes.
Tendemos a pensar que estos robots son del espacio exterior
y del futuro y de la ciencia ficción.
Si bien eso podría ser cierto,
me gustaría exponer que los robots están aquí hoy,
y viven y trabajan entre nosotros ahora.
Estos son dos robots que viven en mi casa.
Uno aspira los suelos y el otro corta la hierba
todos los días.
Lo que es más de lo que yo haría si tuviera tiempo para hacer estas tareas,
y probablemente lo hacen mejor de lo yo lo haría.
Este realmente se ocupa de mi gatito.
Cada vez que usa la caja, la limpia,
que no es algo que tenga ganas de hacer,
y hace mejor la vida de mi gato y la mía.
Y mientras llamamos a estos robots:
es un "robot aspirador, es un robot cortacésped,
es una caja de robot más pequeña",
creo que hay muchos otros robots escondidos a plena vista
que se han vuelto tan increíblemente útiles
y mundanos
que los llamamos, por ejemplo, "lavavajillas", ¿verdad?
Reciben nuevos nombres.
Ya no reciben el nombre de robot
porque sirven para un objetivo en nuestras vidas.
Igualmente, un termostato, ¿verdad?
Sé que mis amigos robotistas
quizá se encojan de hombros al verme llamar a esto un robot,
pero sirve a un objetivo.
Su objetivo es tener mi casa a la temperatura de 19 ºC
y percibir el entorno.
Sabe que está un poco frío,
hace un plan y luego actúa en el mundo físico.
Es robótica.
Incluso si no se parece a Rosie the Robot,
está haciendo algo que es realmente útil en mi vida
para no tener que preocuparme
de subir y bajar la temperatura yo misma.
Y creo que estos sistemas viven y trabajan entre nosotros ahora,
y no solo estos sistemas viven entre nosotros,
sino que probablemente también sean usuarios de robots.
Cuando conducen el auto,
es como estar manejando maquinaria.
También uno va del punto A al punto B,
pero su auto probablemente disponga de dirección asistida,
probablemente tenga un sistema de frenado automático,
o un cambio de marchas automático y quizá control de velocidad adaptativo.
Y aunque no sea un automóvil completamente autónomo,
tiene pedazos de autonomía,
y son muy útiles
y nos hacen manejar más seguros,
y parece como si fueran invisibles al usarlos, ¿verdad?
Cuando manejamos el auto,
simplemente sentimos que vamos de un lugar a otro.
No parece algo especial lidiar y operar
y utilizar controles
porque pasamos tanto tiempo aprendiendo cómo conducir
que los actos se han convertido en extensiones de nosotros mismos.
Cuando estacionamos el auto en ese espacio estrecho de garaje,
sabemos dónde están los rincones.
Y cuando conducimos un auto alquilado que no hemos conducido antes,
toma algo de tiempo acostumbrarse a su nuevo cuerpo de robot.
Y esto también aplica a las personas que manejan otros tipos de robots.
Me gustaría compartir con Uds. algunas historias sobre eso.
Lidiando con el problema de la colaboración remota.
En Willow Garage tenía un compañero de trabajo llamado Dallas,
y Dallas era así.
Trabajaba desde su casa en Indiana en nuestra compañía en California.
Él era una voz en una caja sobre la mesa en la mayoría de nuestras reuniones,
lo que estaba bien, excepto
si teníamos un debate acalorado y no nos gustaba lo que decía,
podíamos simplemente colgar el teléfono.
(Risas)
Y podíamos tener una reunión tras esa reunión
y tomar las decisiones en el pasillo
cuando él ya no estaba allí.
Y eso no era tan bueno para él.
Y como compañía robótica en Willow,
teníamos algunas partes extra de cuerpo del robot por ahí,
y Dallas y su amigo Curt armaron esto,
que se parece a Skype en un palo sobre ruedas,
que parece un juguete teki, tonto,
pero probablemente sea una de las herramientas más poderosas
que he visto para colaboración remota.
Si no respondía la pregunta de Dallas por correo electrónico,
él podía, literalmente, rodar por mi oficina,
bloquear mi puerta y hacerme la pregunta nuevamente
(Risas)
hasta que yo respondía.
Y no voy a rechazarlo, ¿verdad? Eso sería grosero.
No solo era bueno para estas comunicaciones uno-a-uno,
sino también en la reunión general de la compañía.
Sentarse en esa silla
y mostrar a las personas que estás presente y comprometido con su proyecto
es algo bueno
y puede ayudar mucho a la colaboración remota.
Vimos esto durante el período de meses y luego años,
no solo en nuestra empresa, sino también en otras.
Lo mejor que puede pasar con estos sistemas
es que se perciben como si estuviera allí.
Solo eres tú, es solo tu cuerpo,
y así la gente en realidad comienza a darle a estas cosas un espacio personal.
Y, cuando tienes una reunión de pie,
la gente se sitúa alrededor del espacio
como lo harían si uno estuviera allí en persona.
Eso es genial hasta que hay averías.
La gente, cuando ve estos robots por primera vez,
dice, "Guau, ¿dónde están las piezas? Debe haber una cámara allí".
Y comienzan a hurgar la cara.
"Estás hablando demasiado bajo, voy a subir tu volumen"
que es como tener un compañero caminando hacia ti y decirle,
"Estás hablando en voz muy baja, voy a alzarte la cara".
Eso es incómodo y no está bien,
y así construimos estas nuevas normas sociales
al usar estos sistemas.
De forma similar a como uno siente que es su cuerpo,
uno comienzas a notar cosas como, "Oh, mi robot es bajito".
Dallas me decía que medía 1.80 m,
y lo llevaban a cócteles y cosas así,
como lo hacen Uds.,
y el robot medía aproximadamente 1.5 m, que es más o menos mi altura.
Y él me dijo,
"Sabes, la gente realmente no me está mirando.
Siento que solo estoy viendo este mar de hombros
y necesitamos un robot más alto".
Y le dije,
"Mmm no.
Tienes que caminar en mis zapatos solo hoy.
Podrás ver lo que es estar en el extremo más corto del espectro".
Y en realidad él generó mucha empatía con esa experiencia,
lo cual fue genial.
Y cuando vino de visita en persona,
ya no se izaba ante mí mientras me hablaba,
se sentaba y me hablaba cara a cara,
lo que fue algo hermoso.
Y decidimos ver esto en el laboratorio
y ver qué otras diferencias podrían hacer cosas como la altura del robot.
Y la mitad de las personas en nuestro estudio usaron un robot más bajo,
la otra mitad en nuestro estudio usaron un robot más alto.
Y comprobamos que exactamente la misma persona
con el mismo cuerpo que dice las mismas cosas que alguien,
es más persuasivo y se percibe como más creíble
si lo emite un robot de talla más alta.
No tiene sentido racional,
por eso estudiamos psicología.
Y realmente, la forma en que Cliff Nass pondría esto
es que tenemos que lidiar con estas nuevas tecnologías
a pesar del hecho de tener cerebros muy viejos.
La psicología humana no cambia a la misma velocidad que la tecnología
y siempre jugamos a alcanzarla,
tratando de dar sentido a este mundo
en el que estas cosas autónomas funcionan alrededor.
Por lo general, las cosas que hablan son personas, no máquinas.
Y otorgamos mucho significado a cosas como la altura de una máquina,
no una persona,
y a atribuir eso a la persona que usa el sistema.
Creo que esto es realmente importante
cuando se piensa en robótica.
No se trata tanto de reinventar a los humanos,
se trata más de averiguar cómo nos extendemos, ¿verdad?
Y terminamos usando cosas de una manera sorprendente.
Y estos tipos no pueden jugar al billar porque los robots no tienen brazos,
pero pueden coordinar a los tipos que están jugando al billar
y eso puede ser algo importante para la unión de equipo,
que sea algo ordenado.
Los que se vuelvan muy buenos operando estos sistemas
incluso harán cosas como inventar juegos nuevos,
como el fútbol robot en el medio de la noche,
empujando los botes de basura.
Pero no todos lo hacen bien.
Mucha gente tiene problemas para manejar estos sistemas.
Este es un tipo que inició sesión vía robot
y su globo ocular giró 90 grados hacia la izquierda.
Él no sabía eso,
así que terminó dando golpes por la oficina,
corriendo hacia las mesas de las personas, sintiéndose muy avergonzado,
riendo nervioso con un volumen demasiado alto.
Y este tipo aquí en la imagen me está diciendo,
"Necesitamos un botón para silenciar al robot".
Y con eso quiso decir que no quería que fuera tan molesto.
Y, como compañía de robótica,
añadimos funciones para evitar obstáculos al sistema.
Tenía un pequeño buscador láser con el que veía los obstáculos,
y si yo, como operadora del robot decía, ve hacia la silla,
no lo haría, solo planearía un camino alternativo,
lo que parece ser una buena idea.
La gente golpeó menos obstáculos usando ese sistema, obviamente,
pero en realidad, a algunas personas,
les tomó mucho más tiempo superar nuestra carrera de obstáculos,
y queríamos saber por qué.
Existe esta importante dimensión humana:
una dimensión de la personalidad llamada locus de control.
Y las personas con un fuerte locus interno de control,
necesitan ser dueños de su propio destino:
realmente no les gusta ceder el control a un sistema autónomo,
tanto que lucharán contra la autonomía;
"Si quiero golpear esa silla, voy a golpear esa silla".
Y ellos realmente sufrirían de tener esa asistencia autónoma,
lo que es importante saber para nosotros,
ya que estamos construyendo autos cada vez más autónomos, por ejemplo.
¿Cómo van a lidiar las personas con esa pérdida de control?
Va a ser diferente según las dimensiones humanas.
No podemos tratar a los humanos como un ente monolítico.
Variamos por personalidad, por cultura,
incluso variamos por estado emocional momento a momento.
Y al diseñar estos sistemas,
estos sistemas de interacción humano-robot,
debemos tener en cuenta las dimensiones humanas,
no solo las tecnológicas.
Con una sensación de control, también surge un sentido de responsabilidad.
Y si fueran operadores de robots usando uno de estos sistemas,
así se vería la interfaz.
Se parece un poco a un videojuego,
lo que puede ser bueno porque resulta muy familiar a las personas,
pero también puede ser malo
porque hace que las personas sientan que es un videojuego.
Tuvimos un montón de niños en Stanford jugando con el sistema
conduciendo el robot por nuestra oficina en Menlo Park,
y los niños decían cosas como,
"10 puntos si das a ese tipo de ahí. 20 puntos por eso".
Y los perseguían por el pasillo.
(Risas)
Les dije, "Esas personas son reales.
Realmente sangrarán y sentirán dolor si los golpean".
Y contestaban: "Bien, lo entendí".
Pero cinco minutos después decían,
"20 puntos para ese tipo de allí, parece que necesita algún golpe".
Es un poco como "El juego de Ender".
Hay un mundo real en ese otro lado
y creo que es nuestra responsabilidad, como personas que diseñan esas interfaces,
ayudar a la gente a recordar
que hay consecuencias reales de sus acciones
y obtener un sentido de responsabilidad
cuando se están operando estas cosas cada vez más autónomas.
Esto es un gran ejemplo
de experimentar con un posible futuro robótico,
y creo que es genial que podamos extendernos
y aprender de las formas cómo nos extendemos
en estas máquinas
y al mismo tiempo expresar nuestra humanidad
y nuestra personalidad.
También construimos empatía para otros
en términos de ser más bajo, más alto, más rápido, más lento,
y tal vez incluso sin brazos,
que es algo estupendo.
También generamos empatía para los mismos robots.
Este es uno de mis robots favoritos
Se llama Tweenbot.
Y este lleva una banderita que dice:
"Estoy tratando de llegar a este cruce en Manhattan"
y es lindo y rueda, eso es todo.
No sabe cómo construir un mapa, no sabe cómo ver el mundo,
solo pide ayuda.
Lo bueno de las personas
es que realmente puede depender de la bondad de los extraños.
Lo hicieron cruzar el parque al otro lado de Manhattan,
lo que es bastante bueno,
solo porque las personas lo recogen y lo orientan en la dirección correcta.
(Risas)
Y eso es genial, ¿verdad?
Estamos tratando de construir este mundo humano-robot
en el que podemos convivir y colaborar el uno con el otro,
y no hay que ser completamente autónomos y hacer cosas solo por nuestra cuenta.
De hecho, hacemos cosas juntos.
Y para que eso suceda,
en realidad, necesitamos ayuda de personas como los artistas y los diseñadores,
los políticos, los juristas,
psicólogos, sociólogos, antropólogos,
necesitamos más perspectivas en la sala
si vamos a hacer lo que Stu Card dice que debemos hacer,
que es inventar el futuro en el que realmente queremos vivir.
Y creo que podemos continuar experimentando
con estos diferentes futuros robóticos juntos,
y al hacerlo, terminaremos aprendiendo mucho más sobre nosotros mismos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)